Athanasius if you will be so kind how do
you plan to vote this weekend yes I'm
gonna I'm gonna fold yes you're going to
vote yes explain why the reason is
because I trust more the European
institutions that I trust the
politicians here in Greece these are the
same European institutions however that
have admitted to enforcing more
austerity on Greece than they should
have and who have taken responsibility
for the 25-percent contraction in this
country's GDP does that not concern you
worried you perhaps of course it worries
me I feel like we are in the trap even
for yes or no but the point is that I
cannot trust the Greek politicians so
it's I have to choose and I choose yes
is this a yes for another bailout on the
terms offered by the creditors or in
your mind is this a yes or no vote on
membership in the eurozone it is exactly
what you're taking about it's a yes the
eurozone and to Europe in general I
spoke earlier today with nikos papas you
know who he is he's the number two men
in the government he's the minister of
state that he's effectively mr. tsipras
right-hand man he assured me that on
Monday this country's banks will reopen
even if there isn't a new deal with
creditors what do you say to that you
work at a bank yes I work in a bank and
I I understand that this is not possible
because there are no money in the box in
order to do that so and actually I
follow mr. Pappas and I understand that
this is a game a game a political game
they are playing but it's about our
country so it's difficult there is a lot
of propaganda in this country right now
i have three leaflets in my hand from
the no side Oh X I in Greek means no and
they have a pavilion setup right here
they've got guys handing out these
pamphlets and leaflets how to what
degree is propaganda going to influence
the outcome of this referendum I don't
know we're gonna find out but
I believe that propaganda plays row are
always in situations like that so
because we don't have time in order to
understand to think logically so we use
our emotions and it's easier propaganda
to work you're going to vote yes you're
going to vote against the government who
has the momentum right now and actually
I'm not not going I'm not going to vote
against the bug the government I'm going
to vote yes to Europe not to the I
understand Athanasius thank you so much
Athanasius coos tennis we are here in
the main square in Athens trying to
figure out where the momentum